as California tries to close the 26
billion dollar budget deficit teachers
unions are rallying for more taxes in
Spence Francis Murphy a great teacher
what did you how did you do on the Los
Angeles Times value-added ranking to our
legislators to pass the tax extensions
only through collective action can we
force the Republican minority to do the
right thing for our children
waitis how can already be the problem
when the Democrats control both state
houses in the governor's office teachers
say California needs to pass a large tax
increase and an extension of existing
taxes and where you teach yes I'm a
teacher campaign was to tax the 250,000
are more salary makers to maybe bring
that to a state level bill and to start
taxing the rich so that we can fund our
social programs specifically education
the National Education Association says
California already has some of the
highest paid teachers in the country
Golden State teacher salaries have gone
up 19 percent since the start of the
recession so what do we need this money
for the problem is class size and where
that class size has to go down aren't
there fewer kids going to school at
LAUSD every year then there were the
year before is that stop
I believe enrollment is down in the
school district but when enrollment is
down then they need fewer teachers but
the class sizes still go up not
according to the California Department
of Education which says that LA class
sizes have decreased slightly over the
last five years is the solution maybe
instead of giving letting people deduct
their kids from their taxes we should
tax people extra who reproduce and use
that money to pay for more teachers will
pay the teachers more that's that's a
clever idea but no it's really not the
way we should go there's plenty of money
in this society but the money isn't
being taxed the people who are being
taxed are working people the rich get
away without paying their taxes and your
teacher I'm a teacher where do you see
your churches fight like an Egyptian is
it it's like an Egyptian Shang what the
message is is that we need to
disobedience stopping some traffic
taking over some building
you know the rallies with the balloons
and the posters of the post steps not
gonna get anybody's attention what about
this rally is this too tame for you
pretty much a waste of time well once in
a while maybe you can believe what your
teacher tells you for reason TV I'm Tim
Cavanaugh